ganz schön früh noch für sonntag streben
sonst sind wir immer erst um 10 oder 10.30 am start
an
ist
sein
Thom Walsh, Betty, Markacedt,
Ich muss mir auch gleich noch mal irgendwie was zu trinken oder was zu essen holen, irgendetwas.
Rebuilding Windows 98 Pentium 3. Was gucke ich mir immer gerne an.
Irgendwie sind die Videos alle gleich, ne. Der Dude bastelt immer an alten PCs rum.
Aber irgendwie gucke ich mir die Videos übelst gern an.
Black Ops 1 Still Playable. Oh ja, da ist was von uns angekommen.
Ich mein, das Game hatte mal ein Mainmenü mit Charakter irgendwie, ne.
Es hat das beste Mainmenü von allen, kurze.
Getting Nukes with Terrible Classes.
Ich glaub's nicht, wir gehen ernsthaft nach YouTube-Empfehlung, was wir gucken.
YouTube-Empfehlung in 2019.
Nice. Nicht nice. Lul. Hublul.
Leo, wozu gibt es diese Kapsel an Kabel? Kabel nicht reißt.
Also entweder ist das zum, dass es nicht brummt, dass es nicht reißt oder ist das Kabel ein bisschen flexibel.
Ich glaub das ist eher so ein, wie nennt man das, bei einem Audiokabel?
Dass es nicht brummt. Wie heißt das bei Audiokabel?
Dieses, ähm, ich weiß es gar nicht aus dem Kopf.
Der Bucherl, das ging brumm, ja ich weiß aber nicht wie es heißt.
Interferenzen, ja irgendwie sowas. Ich glaub das hat halt einen speziellen Namen, das Ding.
Historic 1987 IBM PC. Bäh, das ist sogar mir zu alt.
Das ist witzig, ne? Dass man das am interessantesten findet, was man kennt.
Eigentlich müsste man das was man nicht kennt interessanter finden, aber ich guck mir lieber PC-Videos an.
Von Sachen, die ich selbst irgendwie mitgekriegt hab.
Den Keil kann ich mir nicht angucken. Die Videos mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Weiß gar nicht warum das so beliebt ist.
20 Minuten, oh nein.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Ich guck wirklich, ich guck wirklich YouTube-Anfehlung.
Das haben wir letztens doch schon geguckt, das war doch ganz ganz gut, oder?
Also wie man Server rackt, also nicht, sondern ins Rack einbaut, ist eigentlich ziemlich einfach.
Du baust Schienen ein und dann setzt du den Server auf die Schienen drauf, so wie er passt.
Das einzige worauf man eigentlich achten muss, wenn man Server in Rack einbaut, ist dass der Luftfluss richtig, also da wie die Luft durchbläst,
dass das richtig rum ist, das ist aber das einzige worauf man achten muss.
Ganz schön früh, ja, ich weiß.
Ich weiß nicht, was daran schwierig ist.
Guck mal mal, wie man Server richtig rackt.
Das ist Fake News.
Grills sitzen nicht im Operating. Glaub ich nicht.
Nur noch hübsche Grills, das gibt's in Kombination im Operating nicht.
247 Support, gibt's das nicht.
Need for Speed 13 years later, oh nein Need for Speed war 3, die hat mir nie gefallen.
Das ist krass, ey.
Das ist übelst krass.
Der erste ist 1 Minuten 16, ihr müsst euch das mal angucken.
Das ist übertrieben, das ist so krass, die Leute.
Das ist so gestört, wie die abgehen.
Passt mal auf, geht ja nur 1 Minute 20, das ist so übertrieben.
Oh nee, warum hat er komische Dragon Ball Musik?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Die Typen sind übelst krass, Rafa.
Hast du das mal gespielt? Nee.
Das ist ein komisches Game gewesen, wo ich den halben auch nicht nachvollziehen konnte.
Aber ich verstehe, dass es schwierig ist.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Aber gut, die sind halt Leute, die spielen wahrscheinlich auch seit 2 Jahren oder so,
wenn es rausgekommen ist, die ganze Zeit dieses Game.
Aber das ist schon heftig, oder?
Das ist schon heftig.
Ich habe nie verstanden, warum da dann ein Ambus rumsteht.
Also die Dragon Ball Screaming Skills sind am Start.
Ich meine, der hat es drauf.
Warum hat der eigentlich einen Gold Kessel, nachdem man das Game einmal geschafft hat?
Da steht ein Einkaufswagen, weil random Items einfach aus dem Editor platziert, würde ich sagen.
Das ist so heftig.
Also die haben es übelst drauf, die Leute.
Was gibt es eigentlich für neue Spielgrunds?
Hatten die nicht so eine Anzeige, wo man sieht, was als letztes...
Ich finde es interessant, das Game dabei, was kurz ist.
Ja, Batman kann sich einfach in 2 Stunden, 3 Stunden...
Das wollte ich schon immer mal spielen.
Ich habe es mir vor 1,5 Jahren oder so mal auf Steam gekauft, The Hat in Time.
Das soll richtig gut sein.
Habe ich aber nie gespielt.
Man kann Smash Speedrunnen?
Wie kann man dann Smash Speedrunnen?
Ok, das macht auch keiner.
Es gibt nur 3 Leute, die das gerannt haben.
Wie kann man da Speedrunnen?
Ach, das ist nur eine Stage und dann halt...
Das ist doof.
Das ist richtig dämlich.
Run, nicht umsonst nicht nur einer.
Nicht nur 3 Leute seit Jahren.
Donkey Kong Country, 48 Minuten.
Voll die interessanten Games dabei.
Hä?
Warum kann man Mario Maker überhaupt Speedrunnen?
Wie Speedrun man denn bitte schön Mario Maker?
Ok, da fehlt was.
Ach so, jetzt checke ich es.
Das ist kein Speedrun, nicht Mario Maker.
Der Speedrun, diesen Challenge, wie heißt das? Endless Mode?
Das wo man halt die Dinge in Folge spielt.
Weil die Level teilweise übertrieben sind.
Ich finde Mario Maker besteht gefühlt aus 80% sinnlos Bullshit Level.
Und manche sind richtig nice.
Was ist das für ein Level?
Was soll das sein?
Das ging jetzt auch, das ist wenigstens nicht so ein sinnloses Level,
wo du auf dem exakt richtigen Pixel irgendwie abspringen musst.
Aber trotzdem.
Warum hat er da unten Bäume als Bild drin?
Was ist das für ein Level?
Warum?
So, wir gucken uns jetzt an.
Das wollte ich mir angucken.
Kann man Black Ops 1 2019 noch auf der Konsole spielen?
Also ich meine die Antwort ist klar.
Die Antwort ist natürlich, kann man das noch spielen?
Aber wo ich meine Bedenken hätte, ist wie verhackt die Lobbys sind.
Moin.
Ach stimmt, man konnte ja in dem Raum rumlaufen.
Ja stimmt, ich erinnere mich noch.
Das war schon nice, das Game war wirklich nice.
Ja das war wirklich cool.
Das war wirklich cool.
Dass du einfach deine In-Game Währung setzst.
Ich meine im Endeffekt war es auch egal, weil du mehr als genug In-Game Währung hattest.
Fünf Minuten für ein Game.
Das habe ich auch gehört.
Oh guck mal, da treffen die Schüsse wenigstens nicht so wie in Modern Warfare.
Oh was, na gut das war nicht ganz drauf.
Den Spielmodus braucht ich aber auch.
Da sieht man aber wie die Schüsse laggen.
Guck mal, sogar die haben eine Ping-Anzeige.
Die haben diese komischen Balken.
Aber noch nicht mal diese komischen Ping-Balken haben sie in Modern Warfare hingekriegt.
Das ist so frustrierend, weil du oftmals nicht weißt, hast du jetzt gesagt, hat das Game gebugged oder ist die Verbindung einfach schlecht.
Warum, ich habe es gestern im Video gesagt, ich habe es gestern 50 mal im Stream gesagt.
Warum macht man nicht wenigstens Ping-Balken?
Oder warum schreibt man nicht einfach eine kack Zahl hin?
Ich meine, die müssen das doch eh messen, wieder Ping zum Server.
Warum schreibt man das nicht einfach hin?
Das hat übelst Bock gemacht, weil du hast so richtig den Einfluss gemerkt, den halt ein Treffer hatte.
Das heißt, ich mochte den Spielmodus auch.
DLC, Ping-Anzeige.
Ganz wichtig, Tango Down mussten sie immer sagen damals.
Das haben sie in Incon4 gesagt, MW2, Black Ops 1.
Das war ein Hit eben, guck mal, passt mal auf.
Ja und jetzt?
Passt mal auf.
Also wenn das kein Hit eben war, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Das erste Video, was du von mir gesehen hast, war Gamble auf dieser Map.
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Ich habe hier ein paar Wager-Match-Sachen hochgeladen.
Sticks und Stones hat mir wenigstens gefallen.
Was gab es da noch? One in the Chamber? Oh, Gun Game war nice.
Aber One in the Chamber hat manche am besten gefallen.
MLC legit.
Aber man hat in der Kill-Card gesehen, dass er voll vorbeigeschossen hat.
Aber bei ihm war er halt voll auf dem Gegner drauf.
Überlegt euch das mal, ne?
Das ist ein Game jetzt, das ist eine ganze Map.
Weil ich glaube, Gun Games sind die Maps kleiner, oder?
Guck mal, das sind sechs Spieler.
Also es sind zwei Spieler mehr als in Modern Warfare gerade.
Aber die Map ist viermal größer und viel besser gemacht.
Die Maps in diesem 2x2-Modus sind einfach nur der übelste Fail.
Oh!
Spass.
Er laggt.
Auf wieder laggt.
Wie krass er hier reingeknackt hat.
Jetzt will er das wissen.
Der M16 Schuss-Sound war auch so nice in Black Ops 1.
Generell, Black Ops 1 war meiner Meinung nach mein Lieblings-Scot.
Spray, Spray, Spray, Spray, Spray.
Da war jede Waffe unterschiedlich.
Bis auf die SMGs. Die SMGs waren teilweise beknackt in Black Ops 1.
Nicht alle, aber es war alles mehr oder weniger.
Wir haben starten.
Bis auf die SMGs, die waren teilweise sehr gleich in Black Ops 1.
Aber ansonsten war jede Waffe einzeln.
Wir müssen jetzt mal gucken.
Der M16 Schuss-Sound war für komplett anders als der Rest.
Die Endfield war ein bisschen 0-15.
Allerdings hat es sich auch unterscheiden, weil sie relativ genau war und langsam geschossen hat.
Das ist der M14 Single Schuss-Sound.
Das ist der Farmers.
Das ist der Galil.
Die war relativ genau, hat aber auch langsamer geschossen.
Das hat alles irgendwie so eine AUG.
Die habe ich, glaube ich, so gut wie nie gespielt in Black Ops 1.
Das war auch Single Schuss.
Gut, war relativ ähnlich zur M14.
Aber man sieht schon, es gibt nur 1, maximal 2 Waffen, die ähnlich sind.
Das ist der AK-47.
Auch relativ genau, hat aber einen merkwürdigen Recoil gehabt.
Schali, super nice.
Commando war auch cool.
G14, G11 war wieder was komplett anderes mit eingebautem Scope.
Die Submachine Guns, die waren ein bisschen fail.
Also hier zum Beispiel Scorpion, Mac und die Uzi und das Ding und die MPL und die Spectre.
Die Paris, die waren alle jetzt nicht so großartig unterschiedlich.
Was rausgestochen hat bei den beiden SMGs in Black Ops war halt die AK-74U.
Das war es eigentlich.
Der Rest war ziemlich gleich.
Guck mal, 30 Damage.
30, 30, 30, 30, 30, 30, 40, 30, 50.
Ach nee, die Scorpion war das kleine Ding, was übelst Damage gemacht hat im Nahkampf,
aber über Range gesackt hat.
Genau.
Stimmt, ich erinnere mich.
Die hat im Nahkampf 2 hitted, die Scorpion, allerdings war die über Range,
da hat die Damage Vorlauf Boom gehabt.
Shotguns, da gab es nur 3 oder so.
Olympia war auch Double Shot Shotgun, übelst nice.
One Shot, Auto Shotgun, also Single Auto Shotgun.
Und das war eine richtige Auto Shotgun, oder?
Ich glaube, die hat kaum einer gespielt.
LMG legit.
Gut, LMG hast du kaum gespielt in Black Ops 1.
Die war ganz cool hier.
War mehr oder weniger ein Assault Rifle, hatte keinen Damage Vorlauf gehabt.
Reifers gab es auch nur 5 oder so was.
Das Ding hat keiner gespielt, das Ding haben die Noobs gespielt,
das haben die, die beiden haben die LMG legit 360,
No Scope, Scope, Quick Scope Leute gespielt.
Die 2.
Hauptsächlich die L96 ganzen Scope.
Wenn sie möchtigen, Face Leute, haben alle L691 gespielt.
Das war's.
Alle Waffen, reicht doch.
Reicht doch dicke.
Alle Waffen und dafür, bis auf beiden SMGs,
einfach alles unterschiedlich.
Das mochte ich übrigens auch an Battlefield 3.
Die Pistole lädt Seite, mit der Pistole lädt nicht.
Was auch immer.
Irgendwie leckt mein Rechner gerade was da los.
Ah nee, jetzt ist der OBS wieder kaputt.
Das OBS wieder ganz.
OBS spackt immer rum, wenn man Adminprächtigung.
Warum spackt mein Rechner rum gerade?
Ist doch gar nichts, wo es was rumzuspacken gibt.
OBS mit ganzen 7% CPU Last ist ja nix.
Scripted 64 Sandbox, das ist eine Windows.
Das stimmt, Battlefield 4 hatte extrem viele Waffen.
Aber ich finde, es braucht gar nicht so extrem viele Waffen.
Battlefield 4 ist ja komplett eskaliert,
was Waffen und Aufsätze angehen.
Aber ich finde es viel schöner, wenn du 4 oder 5 Waffen
in einer Kategorie hast, die auch rausstechen.
So wie in Bad Company 1 zum Beispiel.
Da war jede Waffe komplett unterschiedlich.
Neue CoD ist shit, oder?
Man kann ehrlich gesagt wenig draus ableiten aus diesem Modus.
Weil das ist ein Modus, den will eh keiner spielen.
Besonders geprankt.
Die meisten Leute wollen TDM Killstreak bashen.
Ich glaube, man kann er wenig ableiten.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch eine Variante.
Du machst einfach nur eine Waffe rein,
die du mit Aufsätzen zu komplett anderen Waffen machen kannst.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Ansatz.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Ich meine, da wird das Game nur hochgeladen haben,
weil er gewonnen hat.
Aber es ist echt mal nice, wieder Black Ops 1 zu sehen.
Läuft das Stream einschlüssig?
Ne.
Was ist das?
Hab ich gerade gesehen?
Moment.
Muss man die Bitrate ein bisschen runter machen.
Video, Output.
Mach mal auf 4000 runter.
Jetzt sollte das viel besser laufen.
Streamst du im Schlafanzug?
Ich würde es nicht Schlafanzug nennen,
aber ich habe mich nicht irgendwie groß an den Job gezogen.
Ich habe nur kurz Hose an und ohne Hemd.
Aber ich habe was an.
Moment, das haben wir gar nicht gesehen.
Moment, ich habe gar nicht zugeguckt.
L690, Autoschneiper.
Dann dieser komische RPG.
RGB.
Schreckt.
Ach, das war dieses Auto-Ding.
Das Lore-Teil.
Looptube, Granatwerfer.
Musik, die Black Ops 1 Musiker.
Jetzt kommt Crossbow.
Oh, da hat er Glück gehabt.
Da hat er richtig Glück gehabt,
dass er gleich mit dem Crossbow einen vor die Dase laufen hatte.
Und das Ballistic Knife war auch nice.
Das Ballistic Knife haben sie ja in Black Ops 4.
Das ist ja auch wieder drin.
Bloß, das ist in Black Ops 4, haben sie es voll übertrieben.
Die haben sich gedacht, ey, wir haben keine Ahnung,
was wir machen oder wir haben keinen Bock,
irgendwas ordentlich zu machen.
Deswegen übertreiben wir es jetzt voll.
In Black Ops 4 hast du jetzt ja auch ein Ballistic Knife.
Allerdings ein Dual-Wheeled Ballistic Knife,
was du nur über Kisten Pay to Win ziehen kannst.
Und es soll mega OP sein in Black Ops 4.
Oh, they come back.
Erst mal in A geschossen.
Oh, Nuke Town, Nuke Town.
Jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen, Nuke Town.
Das TDM? Das TDM.
TDM, Nuke Town.
Es gibt ja wohl kaum was Klassischeres für Black Ops 1 als das.
Wobei ich Nuke Town immer Pack Map fand.
Die werden dasselbe doch im neuen Cod machen oder nicht?
100%
101%
Deswegen glaube ich auch,
das ist eigentlich ein Thema für ein Video.
Ich glaube, dass Modern Warfare mal wieder
im Kern ein ganz gutes Call of Duty wird.
Es wird allerdings trotzdem kacke werden,
weil sie so etwas in Richtung Black Market
oder irgendwas in der Richtung einbauen werden,
nachdem die Reviews raus sind.
Das euch.
Das Game wird im Kern ganz gut werden,
habe ich so im Gefühl.
Aber sie werden es selbst verkacken.
Taugst du mit dem Freesie eigentlich noch BDO
oder habt ihr keinen Kontakt mehr?
Weder noch.
Wir haben Kontakt, aber wir spielen kein BDO.
Wir fahren ja ein Spiel ab und zu in meinen Account.
Ich habe da jetzt sonst was für Gear wahrscheinlich
auf meinem Account,
aber Video Game, das hat mich nie so gekätscht.
Oh, G11, jawoll.
Eigentlich war die Waffe gar nicht so gut,
aber trotzdem bock gemacht wegen dem eingebauten Scope.
Das bräuchte auch mal ein Video.
Max macht Waffensounds.
Aber angeblich ist es ja vorbei,
weil Dedicated Servers, ihr wisst ja.
Das war ein richtig guter Sporthander,
der dieser Granate hinter diesem Auto auf Nuketown.
Macht eigentlich Kaboom, ist schon ein Jahr her,
obwohl ich was...
Ich weiß nicht, was der gerade macht.
Abhalmstrike, jawoll.
Erst mal die Leute voll reingerannt.
Das sind aber auch wieder übelsten Bot-Gegner.
Falsche Richtung, jawoll.
Delude, delude, delude.
Die Spawns auf Nuketown,
guckt euch diesen Stumpfchen mal an,
das ist doch nicht normal.
Wollen wir jetzt erstmal eine Runde in den Hundel raushauen.
Ich hab hier eine Xbox One.
Ich müsste mal meine Black Ops 1 CD suchen,
äh, DVD suchen.
Du müsst fast mal eine Runde Black Ops spielen, wieder.
Oder ich spiel's gleich auf der 360.
Besten spiel's gleich auf der 360.
Mit dem Xbox-Control auch, das wird was.
Naja, ich kann's dir beim Fabian sagen,
der Fabian hatte auf jeden Fall keinen Bock mehr auf YouTube.
Das ist ja bei mir auch ein bisschen.
Ich find, YouTube ist als Plattform mittlerweile
so extrem für den Arsch,
dass ich da auch meine Motivationsprobleme hab, ja.
Chopper-Gunner und Hunde draußen,
das war so übertrieben mit dem Game.
Wenn du Chopper-Gunner, also nicht Chopper-Gunner,
wenn du, ne, wie heißt das Ding,
den Attack-Helikopter und Hunde und so,
zwei Kills, die Gegner sind nicht aus dem Spawn gekommen.
Vor allem nicht bei Nuke Town.
Und auf Nuke Town war Chopper-Gunner eh das Niceste.
Wenn die Gegner das nicht abgeschossen haben.
Wenn du den Chopper-Gunner spawnen konntest
und sie einmal im Spawn drinne hattest,
konnten die, hatten die noch nicht mal Zeit,
wenn du gut die Gegner gesporn-killed hast,
hatten die noch nicht mal Zeit, irgendwie großartig
ihren Raketenwerfer rauszuholen.
Aber das, was wir hier sehen, ist der Grund,
warum Leute Call of Duty spielen.
Die wollen die Nuke splashen mit Killstreaks.
Ganz ehrlich, Leute, habt ihr Bock,
TDM zu spielen in Call of Duty,
wo es Killstreaks bis zu 20 Kills oder so gibt
und dann übelsten Tryhard-Gegner zu haben,
also nicht nur die Tryhard-Gegner,
die übelsten guten Tryhard-Gegner zu haben,
wo ihr und sie nicht über drei Kills kommen,
ist doch langweilig.
Du willst, in Call of Duty willst du Noobs bashen.
Wie willst du sonst die hohen Killstreaks erreichen?
Entweder Reverse-Boostest du,
dass du so schlecht eingerankt wirst,
dass du wieder gegen Noobs spielst,
was irgendwie auch vollkommen hinrissig ist irgendwo.
Ja, aber das war's, ja.
Du willst Noobs bashen in Call of Duty.
Und Noobs bashen heißt ja nicht,
dass du nur gegen Noobs spielen musst,
sondern einfach, dass du wild mit Leuten zusammengewürfelt wirst.
Du hast halt ab und zu mal ein paar Lobbies,
wo halt die übelsten Kackbobs-Noobs drin sind.
Das ist doch so, dafür willst du das.
Wozu gibt es sonst 20-20er-Killstreaks,
wenn du die nicht erreichen kannst?
Gegen gute Leute erreicht niemand ein 20er-Killstreak.
Aber wenn du die nicht erreichen kannst,
dann kannst du die nicht erreichen.
Das ist die nächste Variante.
Du spielst im Team und hast halt Support am Start.
Könnt ihr euch noch in MW3,
oder wo das war,
auf dieser Map mit der Satellitenschüssel dran erinnern,
wie du mit Claymores Spawn-Punkte manipulieren konntest.
Da haben die Leute im Vierer- oder Fünfer-Team gespielt,
haben die Spawn-Punkte dicht gemacht,
und einer, Dome, genau,
und einer hat hinter dem Bonner mit der LMG gestanden
und den Spawn reingehalten.
Das ist alles instant verreckt,
und dann hatten sie irgendwie ihre 35-40-Kill-Games.
Das war ein toller Spiel, es wird schwer zu topen, aber wir spielen noch einen,
je nachdem wie lange dieses Video endet.
Ich mag die Maps aus Black Ops 1 auch, es gab ein paar Crap-Maps.
Was gab es denn für Kack-Maps in Black Ops 1?
Was war denn so meine Richtung?
Array ging mir auf den Keks.
Array war nervig.
Newtown ist zwar die beliebteste Black Ops 1 Map,
aber ich fand Newtown eigentlich auch nervig.
Havanna war gut, WMD ging so,
Column ging auch so, das war eine DLC-Map.
Final Range war nice.
Ist das der Golfplatz?
Das ist der Golfplatz, oder?
Die war auch nicht so gut,
das ist der Code-5-Remake als Golfplatz, glaube ich.
Radiation, kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern an die Map, ehrlich gesagt.
Das war eine DLC-Map, kann ich mich nirgends dran erinnern.
Hanoi, das war diese Gefängnis-Map, die war auch nicht so mein Fall.
Ah nee, da unten ist es.
Array hat gesagt, Jungle war gut, Column ging so.
Berlin Wall war auch Great Hiding Spots.
Convoy kann ich mir nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Lounge war cool, Cracked war, das war die in der Mitte mit den Häusern.
Die war auch, naja, geht so.
Crysis war das mit dem Strand.
Ja, die war auch ganz okay.
Jugdorn war nicht mein Fall, Radiation kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Discovery, Discovery war das?
Ach, das war die DLC-Winter-Map, die war auch okay.
Drive-In kann ich mich auch nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Sagt mir gar nichts mehr.
Final Range war cool.
Silo war auch eine DLC-Map, die weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Stadion war auch, glaube ich, eine DLC-Map, die war ganz gut.
Stockpile kann ich mich auch nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Sagt mir null, die Map.
Das war nichts mehr.
Summit war cool.
Grid war cool, das war auch eine Schnee-Map, ja.
Tanker 18 war, glaube ich, auch eine DLC-Map.
Ja, die ging aber auch.
Villa war gut.
WMD war auch okay.
Zo zu...
Ach, Zo war...
Zo ist das nicht die Schnee?
Ist das nicht die Stealth-Clown-Map?
Aber Stealth-Clown war doch Infinity Ward.
Geht nicht.
Das Stealth-Clown.
Ist das nicht Zo?
Ist das nicht Zu?
Der Typ, der war eh geil.
Oder weiß ich nicht.
Havanna war gut.
Neue war auch...
Na ja, war das Gefängnis.
Das ging, glaube ich, auch.
HG80 war gut.
Ersatt weiß ich nicht mehr.
Also im überwiegenden Teil fand ich die Maps eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber 50% fand ich richtig gut.
40% so geht so und 10% kacke.
Das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Ausbeute für mich bei Maps.
Ja, das war nice.
Hier konntest du am Anfang rüber Tomahawken
und du hast manchmal die übelsten Kills gemacht.
Tomahawks.
Das links, links, links.
Phamas Beste.
Die Phamas hatte ganz komischen Hipspray gehabt.
Die hat von der Hüfte hat die Phamas irgendwie so geschossen.
Die hat nicht irgendwie so geschossen überall.
Die Phamas hat irgendwie Hüftspray so gehabt.
Aber das war ein nicees Game.
What?
NA.
Er muss hacken, ja.
Wie, das ist ein Ding?
Unlimited Health?
Na gut.
Das ist was ich am Anfang gesagt hab, ne?
Ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum es nicht mehr spielbar ist,
weil eben alles voller Hacksore ist.
Also vergessen wir, dass wir mit Black Ops 1 spielen.
Hast du das mitbekommen vom Community Manager?
Wenn ja, was sagst du, dieser David Wanderer?
Was hat er denn gemacht?
Was hat er denn getrieben, X-Shooter?
Jawoll, Rage Quit.
Das muss ich aber auch machen, wenn ich gegen Cheaters am Start bin.
E2P als Haus kannst du alles machen, ja.
Solange du Zugriff auf die Xbox hast.
Was ja das Schwierige beim Cheaten auf der Konsole ist.
Du musst irgendwie Zugriff auf die Sachen auf der Konsole kriegen.
Was meistens nicht so einfach ist, aber bei 360, die ist alt.
So gut.
Ja, ich liebe die Ironsteine.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Nein!
Ich werde diesen Mann mutieren.
Das war ein guter Start.
Einmal aus einem Blackbird.
Das hätte ein schreckliches Spiel gewesen, wenn ich dort nicht gestorben wäre.
Da drüben.
1, L96, ACOG.
Oh mein Gott, das sieht so seltsam aus.
Das sieht so seltsam aus, aber es ist eigentlich schrecklich.
Diese Waffe hat absolut keinen Sinn.
Was?
Beste Waffe war immer nur AK-74U Rapidfire.
Ging das? Ich kann mich da überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern, richtig.
Kann man zwei Attachements an eine Waffe machen?
Zumindest war AK-74U mit Rapidfire der Shit.
War so geil.
Mit dem Perk.
Wieder.
Wieder Codra.
Max, das heißt nicht Codra, das heißt Cobra.
Die Leute damals.
Ah hier, AK-74U, beste Waffe.
Das war so nice, die Waffe im Game.
Brrrrrrr.
Duckel.
Jetzt sind sie im Arsch, die Gegner.
Aber das ist so nice dazu zu tun.
Ich würde es gerne wieder spielen machen.
Aber nicht mit den ganzen Hacker in der Lobby.
Da habe ich eigentlich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Da ist wieder der Instant-Rage-Squid angesagt.
Warte, wo kommt der her?
Wo kommt der her?
Das sind meine Lieblingswege in diesem Spiel. Ich liebe die Ironside und die Geräusche.
Die M16 war nicht schlecht in diesem Spiel, aber im Vergleich zu anderen Spielen...
Die M16 war besser als die DS.
Die M15 könnte viel besser gemacht haben. Ich wünschte, dass Killstreak in diesem Spiel kaputt war.
Ich würde das Spiel im Shop kaufen.
Hat irgendjemand schon mal die Backwards Compatibility auf der Xbox One verwendet?
Muss dann die Original-DVD im Laufwerk liegen für oder reicht es, wenn man das Game auf seinem Account gespielt hat?
Also nachher spielen wir noch eine Runde Beta, eine Runde Modern Warfare Alpha und dann muss ich mal gucken. Dann suche ich echt mal meine Black Ops-DVD und dann spielen wir eine Runde Black Ops.
Ich glaube, ich kaufe das auf der One. Ich habe meine Xbox One seit 3 oder 4 Jahren nicht mehr angehabt.
Brauchst du die CD oder die digitale Version? Nee, die habe ich nicht.
Getting nukes with terrible class ist wieder der gleiche Typ.
Was wollen wir uns als nächstes angucken? Hier noch mal eine Runde MW2 oder die PC-Building-Geschichte. Oh ne, 39 Minuten, das ist zu lang. 39 Minuten ist mir zu lang das Video.
Mach mal besser jetzt an wegen dem Update. Nee, ich kann jetzt kein Update sagen, da lag der Stream. Das nachher.
Komm, wir gucken jetzt noch mal eine Runde. MW2. Was ist das Ding? RPK? Nee, Dings M60 mit Schalldämpfer oder was soll das sein? Oder M240 mit Schalldämpfer? Schreckt.
Das war schon nice da, ey. Das war schon nice.
Igitt? Ach, das ist nukes with terrible classes. Was ist das? P90 mit Thermal Sight? Igitt? Igitt? Wer hätte denn sowas gespielt? P90 mit Thermal Visier? Ihhh.
Alter. Ihhh.
Oh, hier, könnt ihr euch noch, wisst ihr noch, Leute, Favela, Favela, der, der, das Bart,
wie sie sich, wie sie sich, wie das, das war eines der ersten, eines der ersten so Call
of Duty, ähm, wie nennen wir es denn mal, Call of Duty Social Justice Warrior Rage Geschichten,
das Bart, das Call of Duty Bart, falls ich da noch einer dran erinnern kann, da hing
mal ursprünglich wahrscheinlich hier an der Wand, das sieht so leer aus, da hieß, ähm,
da hing ein Bild, was war denn das, das war ein Bild, da stand irgendwas, irgendwas auf
Arabisch drauf, ähm, und da haben die sich übertrieben, also da wurden, wurden sie sich
übertrieben drüber aufgeregt, weil, weil das Bild auf Arabisch hing in einem Klo und
ein Klo, das wäre ja schon quasi gleich wieder Allah- und Islambeleidigung und sowas und
da haben sie sich übelst drüber aufgeregt und dann ist dann irgendwann sein Infinity
Ward hingegangen und hat einfach gesagt, ok, wir entfernen jetzt die ganze Map und irgendwann
kam die Map dann wieder und das Bild war weg, boah, haben sich da drüber aufgeregt, äh,
meiner Meinung nach vollkommen übertrieben, ich meine, es ist, es ist eine Map in dem Game,
es ist ein virtuelles Klo, auf einer, in Brasilien, ja, die 90 Thermalvisier, das tut schon weh
anzugucken, Payflow, beste, das war auch, das war eine nice Killstreak-Kombi, Harrier-Payflow-Jopper-Gunner
oder sowas, wobei meistens hat man ja Harrier-Jopper-Gunner-Nuke genommen oder, oder, oder Harrier-AC-130-Nuke,
die ganze Flughafengeschichte war vorher, ja, aber das war noch was anderes, die Flughafemission,
die Flughafemission, da haben sich eigentlich, das haben sie gezielt gefördert, dass die
Leute sich drüber aufgeregt haben und, und das im Gespräch geblieben ist, so dieses,
so dieses, dieser Rage aus dem Nichts, über, über Nichts, ist das erste Mal, wo ich das
mitgekriegt habe, mit dem Klo gewesen in Modern Warfare 2, oh, das Messern in MW2, ja, woops,
oh mein Gott, Fakt, Ragequit, du hast es halt damals gemacht, wenn du Nuke erspielen
wolltest, bist du in ein Game rein, lief es gut, bist du drin geblieben, wurdest du
gekillt, bist du raus, hast ein neues Game gesucht, nicht schneller, LP90 mit, mit Thermal
tut echt weh, get out, in MW2 ist man auch extrem schnell gestorben, ja, können wir
machen, ja, fortunate, gerne Nukes, also wenn es gefällt, ne, wir wollen uns ja nicht
zu sehr mit fremden Federn schmücken, aber guck mal, der Edge-Lorder ist da, in 6.90
auch, Chopper-Gunner, genau, es ist Chopper-Gunner-Time, weil erstmal Metallica-Musik rein und gebannt
werden oder gestrikt werden oder demonetarisiert werden, was ich bei den Killstreak gedacht
habe, weiß ich auch nicht, das ist an OP, an OP ist es kaum zu überbieten, wobei ich
gerade das, in MW2, ich hab es letzte Woche, ich glaube letzten Sonntag schon gesagt, wobei
ich gerade das eigentlich mochte irgendwie an MW2, es war alles OP, in MW2, es war einfach
alles OP, so kann man das auch machen, Messern, Leute, ich hoffe er vergisst nicht zu messern,
weil die Nuke ist nicht legit, die Nuke ist nicht legit, wenn er nicht messert, nicht
verified, viele Overwatch, da gilt das gleiche Prinzip, in Overwatch sind immer nur 2-3
Sachen total OP und darum baut sich alle Comp auf, spiel mal aktuell Reinhardt, kannst du
vergessen, für den Arsch, Messer, er hat nicht gemessert, legit zählt nicht, nächstes
Game, wer nicht messert, hat die Nuke nicht legit, die wird nicht anerkannt von mir, was
natürlich unglaublich wichtig ist jetzt, was spielt der jetzt, MG4, Schalldämpfer, Red
Dot Javelin, das ist ja auch eine beknackte Klasse, Alter, Danger Close, Steady Aim, Bling
Bro, achja, genau, kannst 2 Attachments dran machen, wobei es geht, es könnte schlimmer
sein, können wir als Community nicht, weil alle MW2 zocken, das könnten wir tun, aber
ich glaube meine MW2-DVD ist komplett kaputt, die hat glaube ich den Umzug damals nicht
überlebt, Black Ops 1, was ist denn hier gerade los, gibt es so viele Follows, danke
für die ganzen Follows, Leute, wo kommt ihr eigentlich her gerade, kommt ihr von YouTube
oder kommt ihr über Twitch, dann haben wir ihn hier am Start, der SirHitRand hat gesubbt,
habe ich das übersehen, habe ich das übersehen, SirHitRand, habe ich übersehen, dass du gesubbt
hast, das ist übersehen, es ist Batman, Hipper Handsome,
YouTube, YouTube, ja dachte ich mir, weil ich kriege, also anteilmäßig kriege ich sonntags
morgens, also immer relativ viele, viele Follows, aber nicht so viele, sonntags morgens
sind wir immer beliebt in dieser Kategorie, irgendwelchen sinnlosen Zeug zusammen gucken,
scheint auf Twitch beliebt zu sein, ja, kriegst aber jetzt, ich muss jetzt nochmal das Thema
Naisu für den SirHitRand, muss jetzt drin sein, so, perfekt, ich wollte irgendwas gerade
nachgucken, was wollte ich denn gerade nachgucken, Subscriber, legit, Dankeschön, huge, Stufe
1, ein richtiger Sub, kein Prime Sub, ein richtiger Sub, huge, Dankeschön, legit, underscore,
ist der Chat cute oder schläft der Chat noch, Vorti Vorti Twitch über empfohlene Kanäle,
echt, wird empfohlen auf Twitch, ist jetzt eigentlich mittlerweile Wub S freigeschaltet,
immer noch nicht, oder, ne, die aber in sonntags nicht und samstags nicht bei Twitch, kann
ich aber auch verstehen, würde ich auch nicht machen, bei der Gelegenheit, vielleicht soll
ich das ganze nochmal erwähnen, falls ihr Amazon Prime habt und absolut high IQ subscriben
wollt, ja, dass quasi euer eigener, euer, euer, euer Hirn größer wird, dann könnt
ihr mit Amazon Prime, Twitch Prime verbinden und einen Streamer eurer Wahl subscriben und
euch kostet das nicht, kostet nix, ja, ich kann keine Sätze gerade richtig sagen, richtig
aussprechen, aber danke für die ganzen Follows und die Subs, ne, was ist los hier, wen haben
wir denn hier, wen haben wir denn hier bei den Follows am Start, der VB, ne, VFB, 1993,
1 1 1 2, CMakes, Bart is more than love, Crystalsky, Luky, 80, Mean Machine 905, Friedrich, underscore,
underscore, underscore, underscore, Tizzy, ich spare mir mal die Zahlen, die wir alle
hinten dran haben, AGB7, Basic, Plecky, Collazy, Tijuana Gaming, Swift, der sehe ich nicht
mehr, die Anzeige ist bei Steamlabs ist ein bisschen fail, aber die Klasse ist wirklich,
ich könnte schlimmer sein, aber sie sackt auf jeden Fall, bestirbt in MW2 alles so schnell,
erstmal ne Runde Javelin auf die Map ballern, der ist gerade nicht wirklich einer am Javelin
gestorben oder, ihr müsst mich übrigens mal ein bisschen mehr nerven falls ich irgendwelche
Subs übersehe, Host Bike Crash, da bin ich froh, dass es besser geworden ist, es hätte
seit Jahrzehnten gefühlt schon in Call of Duty vorbei sein können, ja, bisschen übertrieben
jetzt, wobei, so übertrieben ist das gar nicht, wenn man sich das überlegt wie lang
es das jetzt schon gibt, hätten sie einfach nicht nur gesagt damals gefühlt bei jedem
Call of Duty Dedicated Server, sondern das gemacht, dann wäre das alles kein Problem
gewesen, hast du The Boys of Prime gesehen, ja übelst nice, ich letztens erst geguckt,
hat mir gut gefallen, ich hab mich schon gewundert, warum das alles so gut zusammenpasst, bis
ich gesehen hab, dass das nach irgendeiner Comic Vorlage ist, wobei sie wohl auch ziemlich
abgewichen sind davon, aber in der Regel, alle Serien die irgendwie Hand und Fuß haben
basieren meistens auf irgendwelchen Büchern, Comics oder irgendwas, wenn nicht, dann sind
die oftmals wir. Übrigens, ich will jetzt mal was zum Thema Serien sagen, ich hab keinen
blassen Schimmer, warum The Walking Dead so einen Hype hat, oder hatte, ist ja nicht mehr
so, was die Leute an dieser Serie fanden, ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen ehrlich gesagt,
was das ist, das ist ein bisschen so, wo ich auch nicht verstanden hab, warum alle auf
Game of Thrones so abgegangen sind, ich hab Staffel 1, 2, 3, ich glaub die vierte hab
ich so zur Hälfte geguckt, und danach wurde das einfach übelst räudig, sinnloses rumgeschwätze
die halbe Staffel, so getan als hätte es irgendwie Bedeutung, und dann ist eine Sache
passiert, was die kompletten, die kompletten letzten drei Folgen obsolet gemacht hat, der
Buchhalter, Stufe 1, hi IQ, IQ vom ganzen Chat wieder gestiegen, dankeschön Prime,
nee nicht mal Prime, richtiger, richtig echter, ich drück einfach mal random Inklage E-Modes,
vor allem des Windows hat es jetzt vor allem was damit gebracht, aber Game of Thrones ab
Staffel 4, wobei ich die vierte Staffel auch nicht mehr ganz geguckt hab, war übelster
Crap, und ab da ist der Hype als richtig angezogen, zumal man auch gemerkt hat finde ich, dass
ab Staffel 4 ihnen die Buchvorlage ausgegangen ist, oh, das war schön geneift, Controller
Aim in 2019, aber ich darf da nichts sagen ne, ihr habt mein Controller Aim vorgestern
gesehen, was Staffel 7 und 8 nicht gesehen, ja hab ich nicht, ich hab 5, 6, 7, 8 nicht
geguckt, ich hab nur mitgekriegt, dass 8 übertrieben gehated wurde, wahrscheinlich zurecht, hab ich
der Chopper Gunner, aber so ist es halt, Harrier Chopper Gunner übt, Harrier Chopper Gunner
übt, muss es sein, echt, Scheiße war's, Scheiße war's, Scheiße fail, MW Spawns alter,
kein Mörder MW Spawns, das ist so unfaire Rage, kacke, Harrier Chopper Nuke ist kein
Killstreak an allen Lebens-Einstellern, ich weiß gar nicht, dass man da keinen Damage
hat, ich weiß gar nicht, dass man da keinen Damage hat, ich weiß gar nicht, dass man da
keinen Damage hat, ich weiß gar nicht, dass man da keinen Damage hat, ich weiß gar nicht,
dass man da keinen Damage hat, ich weiß gar nicht, dass man da keinen Damage hat, ich
weiß gar nicht, dass man da keinen Damage hat, ich weiß gar nicht, dass man da keinen
Damage hat, ich weiß gar nicht, dass man da keinen Damage hat, ich weiß gar nicht, dass
man da keinen Damage hat, ich weiß gar nicht, dass man da keinen Damage hat, ich weiß gar
nicht, dass man da keinen Damage hat, ich weiß gar nicht, dass man da keinen Damage
hat, ich weiß gar nicht, dass man da keinen Damage hat, ich weiß gar nicht, dass
Kacke aussehen. Guckt euch Scrapyard an, das ist, das Ding hat quasi den, den Schrottplatz schon im Namen, ja
und die Map sieht gut aus.
Es ist ein Schrottplatz, es hat coole Feuereffekte für die Zeit dazwischen gehabt, also man sieht man kann auch eine Schrottplatz-Map machen,
so dass sie irgendwie ansprechend oder, oder was besonderes hat und dann vergleicht das mal mit,
mit den 2x2 Maps. Die 2x2 Maps, unabhängig davon wie sie sich spielen,
die sind, sehen einfach kacke aus. Die sehen richtig kacke aus.
So richtig, so richtig wie was denn, was denn Level-Designer macht, der zum, der zum ersten Mal sein Level-Editor aufmacht.
Jemand, ich weiß nicht Leute, hat jemand von euch mal ein bisschen Maps, Maps gebastelt? Ich hab damals, ich hab damals für Half-Life 1, da war ja, da war ja WorldCraft, da war ja der Editor dabei, ne?
Hab ich ein bisschen Maps gebaut und eine der ersten Maps, die jeder anfängt zu bauen ist ein Schrottplatz-Map, jeder, jeder baut ein Schrottplatz-Map
mit, mit sinnlosen, sinnlosen Kisten, Wänden und, und, und Holzaufstellern und sowas im Weg.
Und die Maps, die, die der übelste Half-Life 1 WorldCraft-Noob gebaut hat und, und Container und so, die sehen so aus,
die sehen so aus, wie diese, wie diese Schrottplatz-Ball-Map in, äh, 2 vs. 2.
Genauso, wie der übelste kacke Level-Design-Noob.
Und das nächste, was man dann baut ist, okay, man baut mal ein bisschen Natur-Map und das nächste, was man dann baut ist als Level-Designer-Noob, äh, Noob ist so ne Map wie Pine 2 vs. 2.
Das ist das nächste, was man dann baut. Man baut mal ne Map, ne Mini-Map mit zwei gegenüberliegenden Spawns und baut ein paar Bäume rein.
Das ist das nächste, was man baut und dann stellt man fest, die Map spielt sich kacke, also was macht man?
Man stellt nen Container rein und, und zwei Autos und fertig ist Pine.
So, so miese, also vom, vom, von der Optik und vom Design-Standpunkt her Maps, ähm, hab ich, hab ich selten gesehen, wie in diesem 2 vs. 2-Modus.
Also die sind richtig schlecht, die 2 vs. 2-Maps.
Das wirkt wirklich, als hätten sie den Praktikant dran gesetzt.
Der Praktikant hätte Level, hätte, hätte gelernt, wie man den Level-Editor bedient, hätte irgendwie in seinen drei Wochen, wo er da war, fünf Maps erstellt,
und dann haben sie sich gedacht, oh nee, ja, ey, lass mal nen Spielmodus in diese zwei Maps bauen.
Ich find, vom Ansatz her, ist dieser 2 vs. 2-Spielmodus in, in, in Modern Warfare gar keine so doofe Idee.
Vor allem, weil es die ganze, ganze Random-Geschichte aus, aus Perks und, und, und sowas raus sind, weil jeder immer quasi mirrored spielt.
Aber die Maps sind einfach übertrieben, räudig, dämliche, Kack-Maps.
This guy needs four more kills to end the game. Crap. He's right over there, dude. Come on, just run out.
Needs two more kills, I need three. This is not good.
Jawoll. Oh, der andere braucht noch einen Kill.
Oh my gosh, let's go. Bam. Let's go.
Nicht gemessert, nicht gemessert. No, it's insane, he has 30 kills too. Let's go, baby.
Du musst messern, du musst messern, messern, messern, messern, messern.
Ja, er setzt. Die ist legit die Nuke, die zählt.
Oh, oh my god. Die Nuke zählt.
Noch einer, ey, der Typ will's wissen.
Also, ich muss sagen, die Videos von ihm gefallen mir echt gut, jo.
Und er hat nur 208 Subs.
Eigentlich voll wenig.
Für die Gameplays. Gameplays sind huge nice.
Geez, Louise.
M16 ACOG, auch übelste Suckerklasse.
Everyone's gonna noob tube now.
Anyone else? I just want the scav pack somehow.
Completely out of there.
Harrier's nice and early, that's good.
Not getting me any kills though, that's not good.
They're all camping in there.
Alright, we'll see. Camp mit der Höhle, ja.
Thank you. Being shot down and dodged it.
Nice. Someone's shooting it, look.
Alright, we got an AC130, good, good, good.
Let's see if I can get some kills with this.
Genau, erstmal ins Handfeld legen.
He didn't pass?
Jawoll.
Die 100, die 120mm-Ding.
Alright, where are they?
In spawn, jawoll, so geht das.
Bam.
No, I didn't get a headshot.
Okay, okay.
Can that get a kill?
Das hat sich auch übelst geil angefühlt in dem Game.
Wenn du...
Wenn du ein 120mm-Geschütz abgeschossen hast.
Und das ging schon raus, weil es abgelaufen ist.
Und das flog noch und hat dann eins, zwei, drei, vier Leute gekillt.
Das war so nice.
Der kriegt jetzt wahrscheinlich keine Nuke.
Der wird jetzt wahrscheinlich gekillt von der Seite.
Eins vor...
Eins vor Nuke.
Vorbei genügt tut.
Fuck.
Ich sag doch, er stirbt eins vor Nuke.
Ich sag's doch.
Ich spiele einfach nur Runde Black Ops 1.
Ich suche nachher mal meine DVD.
Dann kann ich endlich mal wieder meine Xbox anwerfen.
COD ist einfach das Game, worum geraget wird.
Es gibt kein anderes Game, wo man so extrem rumrageden kann wie COD.
Overwatch geht auch, aber nicht so sehr wie COD.
NW2 ist glaub ich die DVD kaputt.
Viele.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie mich registriert.
Ne, zerkratzt, nicht zerbrochen.
Zerkratzt, aber nicht einfach nur zerkratzt.
Sondern es ist von der Reflektionsschicht, es sind Teile abgebrochen.
Die DVD kannst du nicht ganz vergessen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass diese DVD irgendwie funktioniert noch.
Xbox 360 oder Xbox One?
Wenn schon, würde ich es auf der Xbox One spielen.
Allerdings würde ich es am liebsten mit dem 360 Controller spielen, weil ich mit dem 360 Controller am besten kann.
Auf Steam?
Ich glaube, man kann Black Ops auf dem PC nicht spielen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich verhackt sein ohne Ende.
Außerdem sehe ich es nicht ein, dafür noch mal 30 Euro auszugeben.
Das ist viel zu teuer.
Black Ops 1 hat einen sehr guten Job gemacht, als es aktuell war für die 1-2 Jahre jeetfrei zu sein.
Ich habe keinen Call of Duty Order und habe keine
Also ganz ohne
punkt.
Ich hab' keinen Call of Duty auf der Konsole erlebt, was so lang keine Hacks auf der Konsole hatte, wie Black Ops 1.
MW2 war ja im Endeffekt schon fast seit Release.
Ich hab' keinen Call of Duty auf der Konsole erlebt, was so lang keine Hacks auf der Konsole hatte.
Ich hab' keinen Call of Duty auf der Konsole erlebt, was so lang keine Hacks auf der Konsole hatte, wie Black Ops 1.
Ich hab' keinen Call of Duty auf der Konsole erlebt, was so lang keine Hacks auf der Konsole hatten.
Ich hab' keinen Call of Duty auf der Konsole erlebt, was so lang keine Hacks auf der Konsole hatten, wie Black Ops 1.
Ich hab' keinen Call of Duty auf der Konsole gehabt.